[Musique]
les douze apôtres à strasbourg ce n'est
pas seulement une image biblique pour
certains et notamment pour les touristes
en ce moment c'est aussi un endroit qui
près de la cathédrale mail sans vergogne
le sacré aux païens c'est un lieu où
l'on aime se retrouver lorsqu'il fait
très chaud
caroline deans et christophe camus iris
nous propose d'y faire un petit tour
[Musique]
douze apôtres m du forcément avec la
présence de la cathédrale et les
vocations la tante de la sainte cène du
chiffre 12 traditionnels chiffres des
étoiles européennes ainsi de suite
c'est vraiment le symbole même de la
convivialité la cern qu'est ce que vous
voulez faire ici si je dépression j'ai
bu quatre pression c'est fini après ça
accélère blonde vous venez souvent tous
les jours chaque fois qu'on fait une
petite course en mules ont fait un tour
ici 2 3 je goûte quotidiennement les
multiples bière gouverneur avec une
paille
évidemment c'est par leurs traditions se
boit de la bière
c'est c'est ce que j'aime ça snobisme
un peu oui enfin c'est sur des ponts des
jeunes contre les bacs
c'est cela dans mes petits
thibault ça fait combien de temps que
c'est ouvert
cinquante trois semaines à peu près et
avant des études de droit qui devait me
conduire un poste de commissaire de
police c'est l'examen s'est passé de
façon différente que prévu et je me suis
mis à la retraite tout de suite en haut
en bas et douze apôtres pour vous ça
représente quoi
way of life en fait cette une
je crois que c'est une institution je
préfère qu avec le maître anglais
m
[Musique]